وبعد ثلاثه سنوات من رصدها اول مره حوت
تجسس روسي يظهر مجددا وايلين ماسك متهم
بالتناقض ومع حريه التعبير المطلقه او
ضدها ورائد الفضاء السعوديه تودع محطه
الفضاء الدوليه بالدموع وتبدا مع زميلها
علي رحله العوده للارض اهلا بكم
[موسيقى]
في حوت متهم بانه جاسوس روسي يعني يمكن
تفكروا انه هذا الخبر مزحه وحقيقه لكنه في
الواقع حقيقه ودوليه كمان والموضوع له كذا
سنه يعني واليوم رجعوا برصدوا الحوت مره
ثانيه
[موسيقى]
القصه بدات في 2019 لما ننمسك حوت من نوع
بلوغا في القطب الشمالي قرب النرويج وكان
مربوط في جسمه معدات وان قال انه جاسوس
اللي شفناها هذه مشاهد لما شافوا اول مره
المعدات اللي لقيوها مربوطه فيه كان فيها
قاعده كاميرا وكان مكتوب عليها معدات
وهذا الشيء خلى النيروجين يقولوا انه في
الغالب جاسوس روسي وقالوا انه اتعودوا او
تعود هذا الحوت على البشر كان دليل على ما
يبدو انه تم تدريبه من قبل الروس على
التجسس وانه جاء من منشاه عسكريه روسيه
وسمو الحوت وقتها حتى هافال ديمير هافال
معناها حوت بالنرويجي ودمير اخذوها من
فلاديمير اسم بوتين الاول عشان يصير اسم
الحوت الحوت فلاديمير في اشاره للرابط مع
روسيا ووقتها موسكو ما ردت على اي من
الكلام النرويجي هذا امس وبعد اكثر من
ثلاثه سنين منظمه وانويل اللي هي منظمه
نرويجيه بديرها عدد من الشباب لانقاذ
الحيتان وحمايتها من الانقراض قالت انها
رصدت الحوت رصدت الحوت الجاسوس ثاني وهذه
المره في المياه السويديه وقالت انه كان
بيصير ببطء شديد ولكن بمراقبه تحركات
وشافوا انه بيصير بسرعه كبيره في الاشهر
الاخيره الى ان وصل الساحل الجنوبي الغربي
للسويد
طيب مشاهدينا خلينا ناخذ الان صور مباشره
للحظات او لحظات انفصال المركبه اللي
بتحمل علي
وريانه رائديه الفضاء السعوديين طبعا
راجعين الان تبدا الان رحله عودتهم الى
الارض وهم في مركبه اللي هي دراغون وهي
بتنفصل عن محطه الفضاء الدوليه وهذه
الرحله حيكون معاهم اثنين كمان رواد فضاء
امريكيين هدول الرواد الفضاء الامريكيين
انطلقوا معهم في من بدايه الرحله نقدر
نقول انهم الان بيكملوا او خلاص هذه
اللحظات الاخيره من الانفصال وبدايه
الرحله للعوده الى الارض اللي راح تستغرق
يعني تقريبا نقدر نقول انه 12 ساعه وحتهبط
فجرا على في المياه بالقرب طبعا من سواحل
ولايه فلوريدا هذا الكلام حيكون في وقت
مبكر يعني من صباح الاربعاء وطبعا
مشاهدينا هم اللي خلينا بس نذكر انهم هم
قاموا بمهمتهم هذه يوم الاحد الماضي
وقاموا بخلال عشره ايام قاموا ب 14 تجربه
علميه او دراسه علميه رائده فيها كثير من
الدراسات عن بنتكلم مجال الدماغ الجهاز
العصبي الخلايا المناعيه وبنتكلم كمان عن
تكنولوجيا استمطار المياه طبعا ريانه
برناوي وعلي القرني اول اثنين يعني
سعوديين بيطلعوا الى
الفضاء وبصلوا لي المحطه الفضاء الدوليه
وهم طبعا بيكونوا كذلك انهم يعني بكون كذا
وصل عدد الرواد الفضاء اللي السعوديين
اللي طلعوا لي الفضاء ثلاثه وبكده بيكونوا
اعلى عدد لي طبعا او في الدول العربيه هذه
مشاهد مباشره الان بنشوفها وحنستمر طبعا
في متابعه الموضوع لانه في اي لحظه ممكن
تبتدي عمليه الانفصال وانفصال المركبه
الفضائيه دراغون عن المحطه او محطه الفضاء
الدوليه
بالعوده لموضوع حوت التجسس السؤال اللي
بيطرح نفسه هنا هو عادي كده انه التجسس
يصير بحيتان ولا الموضوع تخريف اسئله كثير
يعني بتدور في خاطري بصراحه وتعالوا
نسالها من عمان اللي هو المحلل العسكري
محمد ثلجي اهلا فيك معنا استاذ محمد يعني
ليش ممكن روسيا تكون
ليش ممكن روسيا كنتي تتجسس بحوت
اولا سيدتي قبل البدء بالحديث اتمنى
العوده الميمونه ان شاء الله لرواد الفضاء
السعوديين ونبارك للمملكه العربيه
السعوديه هذا الانجاز ان شاء الله وان شاء
الله الى الامام وانجازات متكرره ان شاء
الله عربيه على هذا الصعيد وفي كل الصعود
ايضا وبالعوده للحديث عن الحوت والحوت ذو
الحظ العافر وربما انه ضاق ذرعا بمعتقله
ومن ثم فر هاربا يبحث عن الحريه وربما ان
هذا الحوت قد نسي مبدا هاما من مبادئ
الجاسوسيه وهو يجب ان لا تبدو ابدا كجاسوس
وهذا ربما ما قد نسيه الحوت وبالتالي تم
مراقبته والعثور عليه ومشاهدته وهو يتجول
بسرعه ببطء ومن ثم بسرعه حول في المياه في
المياه البحر وبالتالي اقترب من السواحل
النرويجيه والسويديه الى ان تم ربما
مشاهدته ومراقبته من اين ابتدا ومن اين
وصل وهذه سيدتي ربما تجسس هو نشاط اجتماعي
بشري قديم يبحث عن التحري عن المعلومه وعن
الخبر بصدق وبدقه حتى
ويتم بناء تقدم انه يعني حوت فاشل جاسوس
فاشل
هذا هذا يعتمد على هذا الحوت وربما ما
يعني سيتم العثور عليه بعد ان يتم تحليل
مسير هذا الحوت ومن اين من اين انطلق والى
اين انتهى وكيف حل به يعني
المقاومه ان ينتهي الى السواحل المقابله
وبالتالي ربما ان هذا الحوت قد خرج عن
السيطره وربما ان الاجهزه التي كانت يعني
قد وضعت على هذا الحوت ربما انه تم
ازالتها وبالتالي انطلق هذا الحوت من
معقله ووصل الى ما وصل اليه هذا الحوت
سيدتي بعد ان تم اكتشافه في 2019 بعد ان
تم اكتشاف الحوت الاول وتم تم فك الاجهزه
التي كانت يعني ملقاه او التي كانت حول
جسده وحيث اكتشف يعني الصيادين في ذلك
الوقت والعلماء البيولوجيين علماء
البيولوجيا البحريه بان هذه الاشرطه او
هذه الاحزمه التي كانت تلتف حول جسم الحوت
كانت معده لتركيب الكاميرات وبعضها معدلي
استقبال بعض الاسلحه او لتركيب بعض قو اعد
قواعد الاسلحه بحيث انها تستطيع تركيب
الاسلحه عليها وبالتالي يعني التحليل ان
هذا الحوت كان هو حوت للتجسس لالتقاط
الصور والمعلومات وربما كان عليه اجهزه
تنصت واجهزه انذار ايضا وربما كان معدل
استقبال الاسلحه او لتركيب الاسلحه عليه
استاذ محمد يعني هل طبيعي يعني انه في
حيتان جلسه بتشتغل جواسيس تابعه لدول يعني
بيدرجوهم يعني ضمن قوائم الجواسيس يعني
هذا متعارف عليه يعني في الاستخبارات يعني
سيدتي
تجنيد الحيتان او او تسخيرها او تطويعها
هذا علم قائم بذاته وكما ذكرت بالبدايه
بانه يعني حينما حينما يعني استطاع
الانسان وعن طريق مراكز البحوث العلميه
واستطاعت اجهزه الاستخبارات يعني العسكريه
والامنيه من تطويع انواع كثيره من الحيتان
ومن الدلافين ومن يعني اسد البحر والفقمات
والطيور ايضا استطاعوا تطويعها واستطاعوا
تدريبها على القيام بمهام تجسسيه
واستخباريه وايضا على القيام بمهام
انتحاريه وهذا متعارف عليه منذ يعني منذ
زمن بعيد فكان لازم محمد يعني انت جالس
بتقول عالم البحار يعني دحين في عملاء
جالسين جواسيس جالسين يعني انت تذكرت كل
تقريبا انواع الناس اللي تحت البحر جالسين
وتحتفل او الحيوانات يعني خلاص بدات
تتعامل معهم الناس بيتجنند وجواسيس يعني
شو هو ده بعض انواع الاسماك بعض انواع
الاسماك ليست مشغوله سيدتي وخاصه اسماك
التونه واسماك الامور الاسماك التي نرغب
بالنتناولها هي ليست مشغوله من هذه
امانه هذولي اصحابنا ما في
نعم نعم
اوكي
جندت
والدلافين واسد البحر وكلهم ايش في اشياء
تانيه نحن ما بنعرفها او ما هي خاطره في
بالنا برضو كمان اساليب يعني بتشتغل في
عالم الاستخبارات او جلب المعلومات
سيدتي عالم التجسس هو عالم كبير جدا وخاصه
فيما يتعلق يعني بالعمليات العسكريه
والعمليات والتجسس السياسي على المستوى
الكبير نشطت العمليات التجسسيه خاصه في
اعقاب الحرب البارده عقاب الحرب العالميه
الثانيه وعند بدء الحرب البارده فيما بين
المعسكرين الشرقي والغربي وكان هنالك نشاط
استخباري تجسسي كبير جدا ويعني اود ان
اقول يعني بان وكاله الوكاله المركزيه
للاستخبارات الامريكيه
قد استحدثت برنامجا في ذلك الوقت يسمى
اكوسيتك والذي هو القطه الصوتيه وكانوا
يحاولون من خلال ذلك الوقت ان يقوموا
بتركيب اجهزه تنصت واجهزه استشعار
واستقبال للاصوات على القطط بحيث يعني يتم
ارسالها الى المراكز المراكز الاستخبارات
الامريكيه وكان الهدف هو التجسس على
السفارات الاتحاد السوفياتي وسفرات الكتله
الشرقيه في ذلك الوقت ولكن هذا المشروع
بعد ان تم صرف عليه ما يقارب حوالي 15
مليون دولار عام 1961 فشل هذا المشروع
هنالك مشاريع اخرى سيد كثيره وكانت
التقارير تشير وقد اشارت مجله نيوزويك عام
2019 بان الاتحاد السوفيتي كان لدي مراكز
ابحاث في هذا الخصوص من تجنيد الدلافين
والفقرات ولا غير ذلك وتسخيرها لاعمال
التجسس واعمال المهام الانتحاريه هذه هذه
المراكز اغلقت ولكن اشارت تقرير اخرى بان
الرئيس فلاديمير بوتين قد افتتح ثلاثه
قواعد لهذا النوع من التدريب في الدائره
القطبيه الشماليه وبالتالي لا يستبعد بان
هذه الدلافين التي تم الانقراض عليها قد
فرت من هذه القواعد اوامر انه قد تم اطلاق
يعني صراحه عمدا بعد ان انتهت مهمه
بس يعني عندي سؤال الان يعني طب
الوسائل التقليديه في جلب المعلومات يعني
البني ادمين اجهزه التصنت الحلوه دي اللي
بتنحط الاشياء هذه كلها يعني ما هي كافيه
شفنا الدرونز كمان يعني في اشياء ممتازه
يعني شغاله
لكن يعني اذا اذا نظرنا الى الى هذه
الحيتان والدلافين تستطيع الوصول الى
اعماق لا تستطيع وسائل التقنيه الحديثه او
الوسائل المبتكره الوصول اليها هذا من
ناحيه من ناحيه اخرى هذه الحيوانات التي
يتم استغلالها في هذا النوع من اعمال
التجسس هي حيوانات ذكيه جدا تمتاز جميل
ايش بيكون في تحت اللي يبغوا يتجسسوا عليه
سيدتي تحت عالم البحار عالم البحار وعالم
اخر مليء بالغواصات النوويه
بمركبات التجسس ومليء بالحركات بالتحركات
العسكريه فيما بين الاقطاب الدوليه
الكبيره خاصه الولايات المتحده والاتحاد
السوفيتي دول الكبرى لديها مصالح في
السيطره على البحار وبالتالي يعني هذه
الدول لا تركن الى المعلومات التي تجلب
لها عن طريق الاقمار الصناعيه يجب ان تكون
لديها وسائل يعني وسائل كثيره ومتعدده
الامر الاخر سيدتي في ان هذه الوسائل
المبتكره كالدرونات يسهل اكتشافها التنصت
على المعلومات واعتراض المكالمات
والتصوير والاقمار الصناعيه جميعها يسهل
التعرف عليها ويسر اكتشافها ولكن في عالم
الجاسوسيه حينما تكون هنالك وسائل مبتكره
لا تخطر على البال ولا تسترعي الانتباه
ولا تستدعي الانتباه اضافه الى ذلك اود ان
اقول لك معلومه مهمه بان هذه هذه
الحيوانات هي امنه وامنه وكتومه ولا تدري
بمعلومات عمن جندها وهذا هو
حيوانات ما حتدلي بمعلومات عن احد من
جندنا يعني ايش حيعذبوه ويعترف
مع اول كف يدون وياه يقول لهم والله بشتغل
للروس مثلا
[ضحك]
ولذلك تستخدم ولذلك انتم استخدامها
لازم انا اليوم طب بس انت سؤال سريع اخير
الفقمه متاكد انه بيستخدموها في التجسس
لان الفقمه شكلها كسول مره يعني
اولا انا سعيد سعيد اني ادخلت الابتسامه
على يعني على محياك الطيب هذا من ناحيه
وهذه ما ادري هو حقائق وحقائق موثقه
وحقائق مكتوبه سيدتي ويعني
انا يعني فعليا اليوم راح اقعد اقضي الوقت
في جوجله الموضوع هذا لانه فعلا مثير
للاهتمام وشكرا لك على يعني يعني طلعنا
على عالم جديد يعني بالنسبه لنا شكرا لك
طبعا كان معنا من عمان المحلل العسكري
محمد ثلجي شكرا لك
[موسيقى]
كويس
المهم خلاص خلينا ننتقل لموضوع اخر طيب
قبل ساعتين وشويه بدا رائد طبعا الفضاء
السعوديين علي وريانه ورئيس كمان فضاء
امريكيين كما ذكرت لكم مشاهدينا رحلتهم
نحو الارض نحن بنتكلم هذا الكلام بعد عشره
ايام قادوها في محطه الفضاء الدوليه
عشر ايام مرت على انطلاق المهمه العلميه
الى الفضاء واللي شاركت فيها السعوديه
ممثله برادي الفضاء علي القرني وريانه
برناوي اليوم بدات رحله العوده وغادر علي
وريانه محطه الفضاء الدوليه وصاروا في
مركبه دراغون اللي انفصلت من دقائق عن
محطه الفضاء الدوليه وكان علي وريانه
عملوا خلال مهمتهم على عدد من التجارب
العلميه ونفذوا تجارب في علم الخليه
وكانوا على اتصال عبر الاقمار الصناعيه مع
كثير من الطلاب اللي سالوهم وجاوبوهم على
اسئلتهم وعلي وريانه كانوا طلعوا في فيديو
من محطه الفضاء الدوليه وادعوا في زملائهم
الموجودين في المحطه وريانه غلبت هد
دموعها خلال الوداع
الات فروميو انا جود ماي تايم هيرون
فيوتشر
اند اوسو ثانكيو
اجري
اند تيك انك
اهلا من جديد ايلون ماسك متهم بالتناقض
ونازله ضده انتقادات كبيره والسبب حريه
التعبير وموقفه منها فمن اول ما اشترى
ماسك تويتر قال انه راح تكون المنصه
المفضله لحريه التعبير وقال انه راح يعزز
من قدره مستخدمي تويتر على التعبير بحريه
وقالوا انه تويتر مو ممكن يستجيب للحكومات
في طلبات الرقابه الا لو رفعوا عليهم
المسدسات لا وكمان وصف نفسه بالدعم لحريه
التعبير المطلقه لكن اليوم يبدو الوضع
تغير والشواهد كثيره اولها احصائيات من كم
يوم نشرتها صحيفه اسبانيه قالت انه تويتر
استجاب ل 83% من طلبات الرقابه
لحكومات استبداديه مثل ما وصفتها الصحيفه
طيب ايش يعني هذا الكلام يعني تويتر
استجاب لطلبات حكومات بحذف تغريدات ومحتوى
مو عاجبها او بيتعارض مع قوانينها
وسياستها واحداثها كان حذف عدد من
الحسابات اللي بتتعارض مع الرئيس التركي
رجب طيب اردوغان قبل يومين من الانتخابات
بناء على طلب الحكومه التركيه وفي امثله
ثانيه اعطتها الصحيفه من الهند كمان وهذا
التقرير طبعا حط ايلون ماسك في مرمى
الانتقادات لكن الشاهد يعني الادهى والامر
على تغير موقف ماسك هو كلام طلع منه هو
شخصيا فالشهر الماضي ماسك كان طلع في
مقابل على بي بي سي وانسال لو تويتر حذف
فيلم وثائقي عن رئيس الوزراء الهندي من
تويتر ماسك رد وقال انه مو متاكد ايش صار
في هذا الفيلم تحديدا لكن عموما الهند
قوانينها صارمه جدا بخصوص ما يعرض على
المنصات وقال انه لما ينحط في موقف بينفذ
القوانين وبيحذف المواد وبينفذ الرقابه او
ينسجنوا موظفينه فاكيد راح يستجيب لي
الرقابه وانه ما عنده خيار ولما طلعت من
كم يوم الدراسه اللي تكلمنا عنها في
البدايه يعني في صحفي في اعاد نشرها
ومعاها علق بجمله ماسك الشهيره السابقه
انا مع حريه التعبير المطلقه ماسك هنا رد
على الصحفي وقال له انت غبي وريني فين كان
عندنا خيار نعمل شيء ثاني وما عملنا
مشاهدينا احنا وصلنا الى ختام حلقتنا
اليوم انا اعود والقاهم غدا ان شاء الله
في حلقه جديده من تفاعلكم في امان الله
[موسيقى]